temporary glasses don't freak out good
morning Hank it's Tuesday today I want
to talk to you about how to win in life
in sports in whatever because I am very
nervous right now and I would like to
send some winning energy into the world
or at the very least some tying energy
but first a bit of background so our
community sponsors a third tier English
soccer team called AFC Wimbledon
specifically our logo occupies the
liminal space between the left thigh and
buttock on their uniform and this has
been a really difficult season for
Wimbledon they've lost more games than
they've won and with two games to go
they are currently in 19th place out of
24 teams and that's a tad worrisome
because the bottom four teams will be
relegated and spend next season in the
fourth tier of English football so in
order for Wimbledon not to get relegated
they need to win or draw one of their
last two games the first of which starts
as I'm recording this in about an hour
it's definitely nervous making but on
the other hand this is actually the best
position Wimbledon has been in for like
months largely thanks to the Walsall
event it's amazing how an entire season
of football or really any endeavor can
come down to ridiculously little things
like Hank I often think that if you're
Harry Potter song hadn't been featured
by YouTube in July of 2007 none of this
would exist of course lots of other
things had to happen to so many that I
can't name all of them or even know
about all of them we all live for better
and for worse with what happens to have
happened but right the Walsall event
with five games left in the season AFC
wimbledon are two nil down to Walsall at
halftime the last time Wimbledon came
back from a two nil deficit was a year
and a half earlier a 2-2 draw against
Barry but then near the start of the
second half Andy Barr Cham is fouled the
ensuing penalty is saved but the rebound
happens to fall to Joe Piggott who
scores and then in the 65th minute while
Taylor scores a beautiful goal and the
comeback is complete - - everyone
celebrates huzzah huzzah except wait
hold on roll that back right there you
see that guy picking up the ball that's
Wimbledon's captain Barry fuller and
he's doing that to run the ball back to
the centre circle to get the game
restarted as quickly as possible now
time added on to the end of the half by
the referee is supposed to account for
all of this but in practice everyone
knows you can save a few seconds by
running the ball back so while everyone
else was justifiably celebrating the
completion of their comeback
Wimbledon captain was like hold on guys
we can still win this and I mean we're
talking here about at most 15 seconds
that is one 360th of the game but as it
happened that was a vital one 360th
because in the final seconds of the game
while Taylor was fouled in the Box Dean
parrot scored a penalty and Wimbledon
won the game 3-2 that meant three points
added to their season total instead of
one three points that here at the end of
the season looked like they might be
absolutely essential so why did the
Walsall event happen it happened because
of accurate shooting because of her
referees decisions because the ball
bounced one way and not the other but it
also happened because Barry Fuller
picked the ball up and ran it back to
the center circle even though he knew
that by doing that he was only
increasing Wimbledon's chances of
winning by some fraction of a percent
there is so much luck in this world and
none of us should ever forget that and
we also all have to depend on the good
judgement of strangers and help from our
friends and colleagues and teammates but
also you have to hope and you have to go
on even when you've lost more games than
you've won and you've been down so far
that a tie feels like winning you have
to pick up the ball and run it back to
midfield and believe in spite of it all
that this game is still winnable Hank
I'll see you on Friday